in this video i want to talk a little
bit about what it means
what it means to be a prime number and
what you'll see in this video or what
you'll hopefully see in this video is
it's a pretty straightforward concept
but as you progress through your
mathematical careers you'll see that
there's actually fairly sophisticated
concepts that can be built on top of the
idea of a prime number and that includes
the idea of cryptography and maybe some
of the encryption that your computer
uses right now could be based on prime
numbers if you don't know what
encryption means
don't don't have to worry about it right
now just need to know that prime numbers
are pretty are pretty important so i'll
give you a definition and the definition
might be a little confusing but when we
see it with examples it should hopefully
be pretty straightforward so a number is
prime if it is a natural number
natural number
and a natural number once again just as
an example these are like the numbers
one two three so essentially the
counting number starting at one or you
could say the positive integers it is a
natural number
divisible by
divisible
by
exactly
2 numbers or two other natural numbers
actually i shouldn't say two other i
should say two
natural numbers
so it's not necessarily it's not two
other natural numbers divisible by
exactly two natural numbers
one of those numbers is itself
itself and the other one is one
those are the two numbers that is
divisible by and that's why i didn't
want to say exactly two other natural
numbers because one of the numbers is
itself and if this doesn't make sense
for you let's just do some examples here
and figure out if numbers are prime or
not
so let's start with the smallest natural
number the number one
so you might say look one is divisible
by one
and it is divisible by itself you might
say hey one is a prime number but
remember part of our definition it needs
to be divisible by exactly two natural
numbers one is divisible by only one
natural number only by one so one
although it might be a little
counter-intuitive is not
one is not
is not prime
let's move on to two
so two is divisible by
and by 2 and not by any other natural
numbers so it seems to make our
constraint it has two it's divisible by
exactly two natural numbers itself
that's two right there and 1 so 2 is
prime
so 2
is prime and i'll circle the prime
numbers i'll circle them well actually
let me do a different color since i
already used that color for the well
i'll just circle them i'll circle the
numbers that are prime
now let's 3 and 2 is interesting because
it is the only even number that is prime
if you think about it any other even
number is also going to be divisible by
2 above and beyond 1 and itself so it
won't be prime we'll think about that
more in future videos
let's try out three
well three is definitely divisible by
one and three and it's really not
divisible by anything in between it's
not divisible by two so three is also
it's also a prime number
let's try four and i'll switch to
another color here
let's try four well four is definitely
divisible by one and four
but it's also divisible by two two times
two is four it's also divisible by two
so it actually has it's divisible by
three natural numbers one two and four
so it does not meet our constraint for
being prime
let's try out
let's try out five
so five is definitely divisible by one
it's not divisible by two it's not
divided by three it's not just divisible
by four
exactly divisible by four you would you
could divide them into it but you would
get a remainder but it is exactly
divisible by five obviously
so once again exactly it's divisible by
exactly two natural numbers one and five
so it once again five is prime let's
keep going just so that we see if
there's any kind of a pattern here and
maybe i'll try a really hard one that
tends to trip people up so let's try
let's try the number
let's try the number six
it is divisible by one
it is divisible by two it is divisible
by three not four or five but it is
divisible by six
so it has four natural number factors i
guess you could say that way and so it
does not have exactly two numbers that
is divisible by it has four so it is not
prime
let's move on to seven
seven is divisible by one
not two not three not four not five not
six but it's also divisible by 7. so 7
is prime i think you get the general
idea here how many natural numbers
numbers like 1 2 3 4 5 the numbers that
you learned when you were when you were
2 years old you're not including 0 not
including negative numbers not including
fractions and irrational numbers and
decimals and all the rest just regular
counting positive numbers
if you have only two of them if you're
only divisible by yourself and one then
you are prime and the way i think about
it if we don't think about the special
case of one prime numbers are kind of
these building blocks of numbers that
you can't break them down anymore
they're almost like the atoms you know
if you think about what an atom is or
what people thought atoms were when they
first they thought it was kind of the
thing that you couldn't divide anymore
we now know that you could divide atoms
and actually if you do you might create
a nuclear explosion but it's the same
idea behind prime numbers in theory oh
and in prime numbers it's not there we
know you can't break them down into
smaller into products of smaller natural
numbers things like
things like 6 you could say hey 6 is 2
times 3 you can break it down and notice
we can break it down as a product of
prime numbers we've kind of broken it
down into its parts
seven you can't break it down anymore
all you can say is that seven is equal
to
one times seven in that case you really
haven't broken it down much you're just
you just have the seven there again six
you can actually break it down 4 you can
actually break it down as 2 times 2. now
with that out of the way let's think
about some larger numbers and think
about whether those larger numbers are
prime
so let me try
let's try
16.
so clearly any number is divisible by 1
and itself so any number any natural
number you put up here is going to be
divisible by 1 and 16. so you're always
going to start with 2. so if you can
find anything else that goes into this
then you know you're not prime and 16
you could have 2 times 8 you can have 4
times 4 so it's got a ton of factors
here above and beyond just the 1 and 16
so 16 is not prime what about 17
one go 1 and 17 will definitely go into
17 2 doesn't go into 17 3 doesn't go 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 11 none of those numbers
nothing between nothing nothing between
1 and 17 goes into 17. so 17
is
17 is prime and now i'll give you a hard
one i'll give you a hard one this one
can trick a lot of people
what about 51
is 51
prime
is 51 prime
and if you're interested maybe you could
pause the video here and try to figure
out for yourself if 51 is a prime number
if you can find anything other than 1 or
that is divisible into 51. it seems like
wow this is kind of a strange number you
might be tempted to think it's prime but
i'm now going to give you the answer it
is not prime because it is also
divisible by 3
and 17. 3 times 17
is 51. so hopefully that gives you a
good idea of what prime numbers are all
about and hopefully we can we can we can
give you some practice on that in future
videos or maybe some of our exercises